[Musik]
das wirtschaftssymposium post konflikt
wiederaufbau als chance fand am
nachmittag des 11
dezember in den räumlichkeiten der
wirtschaftskammer statt wie es im ozean
findet zweimal jährlich im
kontinuierlichen wechsel ja gastgeber
wirtschaftskammer österreich und
bundesministerium für landesverteidigung
statt
in beeindruckendem ambiente des großen
festsaals diskutierten ausgewählte
vertreter aus den bereichen der
wirtschaft und des heeres die
möglichkeiten von kooperationen in
befriedeten gebieten im abschließenden
statement von generalsekretär des
verteidigungsministeriums dr wolfgang
baumann
dank dieser den vertretern aus
wirtschaft und der ministerien für die
aktive teilnahme sowie das einbringen
zahlreiche beiträge in diesem sinne
möchte ich diesen schwung mitnehmen und
möchte sie jetzt im anschluss noch zu
einem empfang ein laden gemeinsam mit
der wirtschaftskammer bedanke mich bei
allen die zum erfolg beigetragen haben
und wir machen das nicht für uns selbst
sondern für die österreichische
bevölkerung für die österreichische
wirtschaft und für das österreichische
bundesheer und für alle anderen
vertreter die heute dabei warnt
herzlichen dank
[Musik]
für das kommende jahr kommt er bereits
konkrete workshopthemen ankündigen um
die kontakte zu intensivieren und so
eine gemeinsame basis und
rahmenbedingungen für post konflikt
szenarien bei zukünftigen einsätzen des
bundesheeres im in und ausland zulegen